grâce aux progrès techniques mais les
prix ont baissé il ya rien pour là avec
une petite nuance quand même sur un
poste très important
qui est le poste du logement ou là où on
observe ces 23 dernières années une très
forte hausse notamment des loyers de la
possibilité d'accession à la propriété
voilà mais ce que je voulais dire c'est
que ce qui est important on se compare
jamais quand on vit on se compare jamais
comment vivaient nos mon arrière grand
mère non on se compare avec les gens
avec lesquels on vit et je pense que le
gros problème il ya deux gros problème
je pouvoir d'achat bien le sentiment qui
est une série de besoins insatisfaits
qui pourraient être satisfaits qu'ils ne
le sont pas mais reviendra dans la
discussion et la deuxième chose très
importante c'est des inégalités c'est à
dire que
ajuste type de mon point de vue nombre
de citoyens jugent qu'il n'est pas
acceptable que toute autre échelle parce
qu'en fait le décrochage les inégalités
se sont creusées
par le haut de l'échelle et qu'on dit de
l'échelle c'est même pas les 10% ces
scellés 1% et c'est surtout parmi les 1%
les 0,1 pour cent convives lors leur
niveau de vie littéralement explosé et
ça ça remet en cause le pacte
républicain le fait qu' on vit dans la
même société
[Musique]